en ligne avec alexei route qui bonjour
monsieur merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes étudiant en droit à l'académie kiev
- live vous répondez à nos questions
depuis tu y arrives dans le nord de
l'ukraine première question qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire de la
situation là où vous êtes ce vendredi
matin comment s'est déroulée la nuit par
exemple
alors la situation n'était plus en plus
graves hier il y avait plusieurs
bombardements de notre ville et c'est ma
terre et continuent de bombarder
maintenant on a eu des sirènes est donc
maintenant je suis au sous sol et j'ai
passé la nuit aussi ici
comme toute la journée hier et comment
faites vous face à cette situation
est-ce que vous avez accès à la
nourriture à l'eau potable au courant
maintenant oui j'ai toujours accès à
l'eau potable est aussi à la nourriture
mais certains certains quartiers des
mavs ils n'ont pas eu accès à tous ces
commodités et quels sont vos projets
dans les prochaines heures vous allez
rester vous allez partir
maintenant je vais rester ici je vais
rester dans ma ville c'est planifié
maintenant qu'on n'a pas des
catastrophes humanitaires je veux rester
ici et j'espère que les
émissions humanitaires vont à arriver
ici avec et la nourriture avec tout ce
qu'on a on tout ce qu'on a besoin est-ce
que vous allez combattre
a maintenant non mais j'ai combat à la
france une formation elle donc j'ai dont
les interviews j'ai un tour de toutes
mes amis tous mes amis internationaux
pour
collecter des fonds pour
la soutenir l'armée craignant est
justement comment comptez vous soutenir
l'armée ukrainienne comme par exemple
vous entendez vladimir poutine dire
qu'il lui qu'il ira jusqu'au bout qu'est
ce que cela vous inspire
cela nous inspire s'ébattre eux cela
nous inspire un résisté parce qu on
comprend que bien qu'ils disent toutes
ces choses la bataille ne va pas elle a
déjà planifié il ya des problèmes il ya
des problèmes graves pour lui et on
comprend que le plus londres résiste le
plus pur efficace des sanctions avant de
venir donc un
nouveau lot à gagner du temps et nous
voulons que le temps et l'europe agisse
si vous aviez aujourd'hui onexim skins
le responsable russe en face de vous
allez vladimir poutine qu'est ce que
vous lui diriez quel serait votre
message directement
je veux dire à la demie routine qu'il
doit s'arrêter on va lui arrêté et
comment
par notre résistance par notre force et
par l'unité l'unité pas seulement
européen en créant une unité mondiale
alors justement pour peut-être entrer
dans les détails un peu plus ce qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire selon vous tout
de suite pour stopper cette guerre
qu'elle serait de votre point de vue la
meilleure décision
alors la meilleure décision je crois
c'est ça dépend de peuple russe des
gares russes qui sont affectés par à
tous ces décisions donc c'est un peuple
russe tagir cd
sont vraiment inquiétant de ces dates-là
s'arrêter d'arrêter
cette personne oui mais à 6 le peuple
russe ne veut pas agir donc l'europe et
l'otan doivent faire quelque chose
doivent se tenir le crâne de plus en
plus parce que un conte vous savez les
attaques sur les plantes nucléaire c'est
vraiment la menace pour toute l'europe
donc pour vous en france aussi alors le
temps a déjà dit qu'elle
n'interviendrait pas militairement avec
ses soldats on a attendu que ce soient
des responsables américaines comme dubaï
des non européens comme your soul
aventure la hyène le dirait l'expliqué
dans la mesure où l'alliance atlantique
ne peut pas intervenir militairement
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'elle peut faire
pour vous
quand même les les pays individuellement
peuvent à thenay les armes pop 1
ainsi c'était de nous soutenir
militairement
ah bien sûr que le n8 a aussi créé
l'émission spéciale donc peut-être que
les pays de l'otan ne peuvent pas venir
ici comme le temps mais ils peuvent pas
venir ici individuellement vous protéger
et vous croyez un possible cessez-le-feu
maintenant je vois que les pays les pays
européens ne veulent pas à agir en
ukraine mais j'espère que
en regard des situations qui se passe
ici c'est sur un possible futur merci
beaucoup merci on trouve au l'excellent
mode qui pour votre témoignage sur
france 24 l'étudiant doit à l'académie
kiev - il avoue répondu aux questions de
france 24 depuis pierre niffe dans nord
de l'ukraine merci hier jeudi du coup